pour faire pousser des pommes de terre
ça va peut-être semblait évident pour
certains on ne s'aime pas une graine on
mêlant terre une patate tous les
producteurs y compris ceux qui
produisent des pommes de terre dite de
semences sont périodiquement aux prises
avec une bactérie qui cause pas mal de
dommages
heureusement des scientifiques pensent
avoir trouvé un moyen naturel de contrer
cette bactérie là
[Musique]
après l'été la récolte des pommes de
terre peut commencer c'est la culture
légumière de plein champ la plus
importante au canada
les deux tiers des pommes de terre
deviennent des frites tous des
coustilles 20 % vont au marché du frais
et 14 % sont des pommes de terre de
semence
le pays est un chef de file en pommes de
terre de semence depuis presque cent ans
patrice bolduc de péribonka et membre
d'une coopérative de producteurs
spécialisés dans la pomme de terre de
semence
[Musique]
une culture exigeant
les chants sont certifiées par l'agencé
canadienne d'inspection des aliments
les récoltes soumises à des épreuves
régulières de dépistage de virus et de
maladie nos premiers plats qu'on arrache
cette année combien de ces riches
antoine deux petits litiges
antoine le dard et l'agronome de la
coopérative permet des patates format a5
producteurs ils récoltent 30 mille
tonnes de pommes de terre de semence par
année vendu au québec en ontario et aux
états unis
ça devrait donner de maurane bonne
nouvelle à première vue pas de maladie
pas de galicie dans le regard d'un
galles commune de la pomme de terre une
maladie causée par une bactérie dans le
sol la streptomycine l'espèce présente
ici hélas caby la bactérie provoque des
lésions sur la peau du tubercule la
maladie est endémique est présente
partout en amérique et en europe
lyall commune je pense que c'est un
problème majeur au québec mais beaucoup
de monde qui en parle pas beaucoup qui a
chez eux ils disent on ne peut pas de
galles en eau potable mais c'est
quasiment impossible on a toujours un
coin qui égale le vendredi qui est tout
temps à risque
année après année
pourtant la pomme de terre attac et est
tout à fait comestible
juste pour lui qu'ils vont racheter la
pomme de terre de semence qui valent à
replanter dans son sol l'huile clients
il veut particulière et rogan
justement patrice boutevin sa récolte à
des producteurs de pommes de terre
fraîches qui eux écoulent leurs pommes
de terre aux épiceries et en bout de
ligne
le consommateur ne veut pas de légumes
avec des petites tâches ça c'est un
secteur qu'on savait carnaval le
problème est amplifié depuis les
dernières années alors que la mise en
marché exige des pommes de terre laver
les imperfections sont maintenant
visibles et le client ne choisit que les
parfaites
le fait que tu esthétiquement c'est
moins beau puis la pomme de terre est
plus difficile aussi à nettoyer mais ça
n'a aucun impact au niveau de la santé
du consommateur en tant que tel
[Musique]
comme il existe au risque de
contamination des sols en plantant des
pommes de terre galeuses
l'agencé canadienne d'inspection des
aliments lait des classes pour la
coopérative
ça représente environ je dirais en
moyenne 5% de pommes de terre là chaque
année qui sont déclassées c'est qu'il
fait là que ça représente environ 3
millions de livres de pommes de terre
qui sont invendus l'eau à chaque année
il y à bien un moyen de contrôler
stériliser le sol par un traitement
chimique à la chloropicrine un gaz
liquide injecté dans le billon avant la
plantation
agent de fumigation n'est pas sélectif
il détruit tous les micro-organismes
vivants dans le sol traité et ce jusqu
au repeuplement des organismes vivants
environ quinze jours après le traitement
c'est une méthode de lutte radicale que
rejette la coopérative
l'utilisation des pesticides c'est ce
qu'on veut diminuer on ira en augmentant
dans ce laboratoire de l'université du
québec à chicoutimi
on a entrepris des travaux en vue de
développer un biopesticide naturel pour
enrayer la gale commune même si cette
équipe oeuvre loin de l'agriculture au
laboratoire la sèvre en premier lieu on
travaille dans le secteur du cancer on
cherche de nouveaux anti cancéreux à
partir de l'été plan de la forêt boréale
c'est un autre chercheur de l'uqac
l'agronome maxime paré qui leur a
suggéré de mettre à profit leurs
connaissances pour venir en aide aux
producteurs agricoles pour le regarder à
ça qu'on saisit peut-être qu'on pouvait
regarder c'est vrai pas d extraire des
composés qui pourrait inhiber la
croissance de cette bactérie la cause
des dégâts importants donc à la pomme de
terre
[Musique]
mais quand qu'ils ont intéressé en
premier lieu sont les plantes qu'on
conservait donc qu'on connaît c'est le
potentiel antibiotiques pour d'autres
types de bactéries
il s'agit d'une sélection de belles
fleurs en premier lieu la verge d'or une
plante indigène très répandue
et d'une autre plante herbacée les
pilotes deux espèces qu'on trouve en
abondance à l'état sauvage
[Musique]
après plusieurs années de tests en
laboratoire les premiers essais ont été
effectués en serre avec de bons
résultats
et là on s'est rendu compte qu'ils
avaient une activité extrêmement
intéressante sur l'inhibition de la
croissance de qu'est ce qu'un pays la
gale la bande de terre on a réussi en
fait avec la verge d'or à une idée 45%
de la gare sur les pommes de terre
un succès quand on sait que la
fumigation parviennent à un taux
d'efficacité qui varie de 30 à 50%
l'étape des essais en champs peut
maintenant commencer
sûrement la première de plusieurs années
d'essais et erreurs
la prime tout pessac été identifiés
c'est la récolte des premières pommes de
terre de semence traiter avec un
biopesticide naturel ici ce qu'on a fait
part à fait on a pris les meilleurs
produits qu'on avait à faire avec les
meilleurs résultats sont en fait des
extraits de résidus forestiers
c'est une combinaison de dizaines
d'espèces de résidus forestiers de
partout au pays et pendu selon un
dispositif scientifique c'est des
parcelles relativement petit 2 mètres de
largeur donc on a appliqué ou non un
produit c'est la parcelle numéro tour
donc j'ai aucune idée
aux fins scientifiques de chercheurs
ignorent quelle parcelle ont été traités
mais à première vue ici il y a des
signes de présence de maladies on est
venu ici d'un secteur juste avant à
cause des problématiques au niveau de la
gale puis bon mais s'est plaint donc on
reproche à musa au laboratoire affronter
tout sauf un peu plus loin ce n'est pas
le même portrait d'une pomme de terre
ainsi qui est exempte de lésions c'est
ce qu'on cherche
ça semble plus encourageants bon allez
je veux paulhan soit un chiffre comme
seul mais on pourrait dire moins de 5%
ainsi que dans alors que dans les autres
l'ont on voyait qu'il ya des pommes de
terre entre 20 et 30 % affecté donc ça
me semble être une bonne diminution le
met encore une fois installé vous mangez
mieux mesurer la dame foncé le chercheur
est assistée de stefanik l'outil dont la
maîtrise porte sur le projet de l'uqac
on est vraiment content de voir on
semble avoir une différence est
visuellement donc selon les traitements
la prochaine étape serait vraiment
d'aller identifie la molécule qui va
être active dans le temps chacun des
traitements donc on va l'isoler et
ensuite pouvoir éventuellement tester
cette molécule sur la gale
[Musique]
le développement d'un bio pesticide
naturel est une longue quête la première
étape sur le terrain on est loin de la
coupe aux lèvres mais faut commencer
quelque part donc l'équipe de maxime
paré doit peaufiner la bonne formulation
déterminé l'application adéquate liquide
ou solide voir à quel moment dans la
saison les traitements doivent être
effectués et à quelle fréquence les
chercheurs ont la collaboration des cinq
producteurs de la coopérative la patate
du lac saint jean qui souhaitent
vraiment une solution naturelle problème
de la gale je pense aux gens d'avoir des
as au chant
[Musique]
même si le produit traitant est
d'origine naturelle d'importants textes
restent à faire quant à son impact dans
le sol c'est sûr que quand on prend un
produit de la forêt ou enfin de
molécules naturelles
ça veut pas nécessairement dire non
dommageables donc pour la pour la santé
ou même pour l'environnement donc tout
seul il faut [ __ ] ou sa demeure est
démontrée à sa demeure à être
expérimentée
leur défi diminuer les dommages causés
par la bactérie streptomyces acabit tout
en préservant les micro organismes
utiles ne serait ce que pour la
fertilisation des cultures la
décomposition des matières organiques la
suppression de dos maladie donc on parle
ici on parle souvent d'un sol qui
ressemble beaucoup à un microbiote au
niveau humain mais c'est vraiment à ça
il faut être en mesure de trouver un
équilibre entre les différentes espèces
de microbes dans le sol pour être en
mesure de répondre aux différents stress
environnementaux
un peu plus de 5 millions de tonnes de
pommes de terre ont été récoltés au pays
en 2010 vidéo
la fumigation a été utilisé sur une
large part des sols en production
d'où un intérêt très grand pour un
premier traitement naturel contre la
gale j'étais assez confiant que d'ici
cinq à dix ans donc on va avoir quelque
chose de solide à offrir aux producteurs
agricoles
patrice bolduc et ses frères travaillent
de longues heures ces jours ci il
récolte ou moins 30 camions par jour
j'espère bien qu'on ait commencé lundi
matin à 20 semaines dans une belle
période de pluie l'eau la terre est
humide ça va bien marcher
la gale commune n'a pas trop suivi
jusqu'ici
on est au début des travaux et patrice
bon duc ne s'emballe pas trop un jour à
la fois secteur de châlons mais en
général au bout cette année ça s'annonce
très bien oui
[Musique]